way outside near the arc green may  angles up toward the room it gives her a  beat he'll turn out  count the bucket  but review  it  catch a turn a shot and  [Applause]  everybody in the building the catch the  turn the shot  look at the philly [ __ ] they're loving  it  [Music]  i am speechless  and be catch turn two raptors on them it  doesn't matter but nobody gets a good  look at three  in bounds it comes to anonymity broken  up by green and nobody gets off the shot  but not in time  philadelphia survives in overtime  joel embiid the most improbable fall  away three-pointer  to give philadelphia the win 104-101  [Applause]  embiid the league's leading scorer puts  33  in the books tonight with 13 rebounds  [Music]